welcome to Modern Agri machines have you
ever wondered how technology is
revolutionizing agriculture from soil
preparation and planting machines to
those that take care of crops and handle
the harvesting modern agricultural
equipment is transforming the way we
Farm in today's video we'll explore the
advanced machines that help farmers save
time effort and significantly boost
productivity let's dive into the latest
technologies that are taking agriculture
to the next level don't forget to like
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
so you don't miss out on our upcoming
videos first we will explore the amazing
technology behind the machines for soil
preparation planting care and harvesting
of carrots and how they are
revolutionizing the agriculture industry
in the past soil preparation planting
caring for and harvesting carrots
required a lot of manual labor workers
had to prepare the soil using basic
tools and tasks like planting seeds and
caring for the crops were mostly done
manually during harvesting Farmers had
to bend down pull each carrot out by
hand and place them into crates this
method was not only slow but also
physically demanding requiring many
workers to complete the tasks which
increased costs for Farmers but now with
the Advent of machines for soil
preparation planting care and harvesting
of carrots these technological marveles
have completely transformed carrot
farming these machines make carrot
cultivation far less time consuming
compared to traditional manual methods
let's take a closer look at how these
machines work and why they are so
effective carrot soil preparation and
sewing machines are specialized
agricultural equipment designed to
automate the steps from soil preparation
seed sewing to covering the seeds with
soil helps save time labor and cost
while increasing production efficiency
and crop yield with continuous and
precise operation these machines are
invaluable tools for Farmers especially
on large scale Farms nowadays Farmers
also use mechanization for fertilizing
and spraying pesticides to save labor
time and enhance productivity the carrot
harvesting machine is equipped with
Advanced digging blades that gently lift
the carrots from the soil without
damaging them the carrots are then
transferred onto a conveyor belt where
they are automatically cleaned and
sorted this process not only speeds up
harvesting but also ensures that carrots
are handled carefully minim iing damage
and waste with just one machine farmers
can Harvest several times more carrots
in the same amount of time compared to
manual methods this not only reduces the
need for labor but also significantly
shortens the harvesting time allowing
Farmers to bring their products to
Market faster and fresher increased
efficiency can lead to significant cost
savings and higher profits for Farmers
there are different types of carrot
harvesting machines available ranging
from small affordable models for small
farms to high capacity machines designed
for large commercial operations each
machine is designed to meet different
needs ensuring that Farms of all sizes
can benefit from this technology from
soil preparation sewing tending and
harvesting by hand to using Advanced
Machinery the evolution of Technology
marks a significant Leap Forward in
agriculture these machines not only help
increase productivity multiple times
over but also reduce labor costs in time
making farming more sustainable and
profitable as technology continues to
advance who knows what the future of
Agriculture will hold one thing is for
sure the days of backbreaking manual
harvesting are behind us thanks to these
amazing
machines soil preparation planting and
harvesting machines for potatoes are
vital mechanization Tools in modern
agriculture especially for large scale
potato cultivation these machines
optimize the steps from soil preparation
planting to harvesting delivering
Superior efficiency and minimizing
Reliance on manual labor potato soil
preparation machines are designed to
provide the best soil conditions for
planting the main components of the
machine typically include plows Harrows
and wheels for movement the plows and
Harrows help till the soil remove weeds
stones and other impurities and make the
soil loose and aerated creating ideal
conditions for potato growth thanks to
these machines farmers can complete the
task quickly and uniformly saving
significant time and effort compared to
manual methods potato planting machines
automate the sewing process ensuring
precise and efficient planting these
machines are equipped with seed Hoppers
and distribution devices that sew seeds
at the correct spacing and depth
according to set requirements after
sewing the machine covers the seeds with
soil protecting them from environmental
factors and supporting the German ation
process the Precision of planting
machines helps optimize seed and
fertilizer usage while minimizing waste
potato harvesting machines represent one
of the most significant advancements in
agriculture drastically reducing the
time and effort required to harvest
potatoes these machines use digging
blades in Conveyor Systems to gently
lift potatoes from the soil without
damaging them the potatoes are then
transferred onto a conveyor belt for
cleaning and automatic sorting this
process enables rapid harvesting
minimizes losses due to damage and
increases productivity soil preparation
planting and harvesting machines for
potatoes play an extremely important
role in agricultural mechanization
particularly for large Farms they
enhance production efficiency by
reducing time and labor while also
increasing the yield and quality of the
produce for Farmers using Modern
Machinery not only helps lower labor
costs but also optimizes farming
processes thereby increasing profit
ability Additionally the adoption of
machinery and agriculture helps address
the labor shortage in the sector
particularly in the context of declining
rural populations in the shift of labor
to other Industries Machinery also
allows Farmers to better manage inputs
such as fertilizers irrigation and
pesticides thereby contributing to
Environmental Protection and maintaining
the sustainability of the Agricultural
ecosystem in summary soil preparation
planting and harvesting Ma Mach for
potatoes are not just mechanization
tools but revolutionary technological
solutions that shape the future of
modern agriculture with the continuous
advancement of Technology the role of
these machines will become even more
crucial helping Farmers boost
productivity reduce costs and enhance
sustainability in farming
practices the corn Harvester is one of
the most important inventions in modern
agriculture optimizing the harvesting
process and significantly increasing
labor efficiency in the past corn
harvesting was done manually requiring a
lot of effort time and Manpower with the
Advent of the Corn Harvester this task
has become easier faster and more
efficient than ever the corn Harvester
is equipped with key components such as
cutting blades Conveyor Systems a kernel
separator and a storage compartment as
the machine moves through the corn
fields the cutting blades cut the corn
stalks at the base then the corn plants
are transferred onto the conveyor here
the separator automatically separates
the kernels from the cobs and deposits
the kernels into the storage compartment
while the stalks and leaves are
discarded this process minimizes kernel
loss and ensures the harvested kernels
are clean and less damage one major
advantage of the Corn Harvester is its
ability to operate continuously and
efficiently over large areas saving
Farmers Time and Labor compared to
manual methods this is especially
crucial during harvest season when
timely harvesting can directly impact
the quality and market value of the crop
Additionally the corn Harvester reduces
the need for manual labor a significant
benefit given the current scarcity of
agricultural workers modern corn
Harvesters are also equipped with
Advanced Technologies like GPS
navigation systems which help the
machines operate more accurately reduce
waste and optimize productivity The
Continuous development of corn Harvester
technology plays a crucial role in
enhancing efficiency and sustainability
in agriculture helping Farmers improve
their profits and maintain stable yields
in the long term technological
advancements in corn Harvesters have
revolutionized agriculture bringing
substantial benefits to Farmers and the
agricultural economy as a whole
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]